tout va bien vous êtes en vacances dans
la région
vous êtes de quel pays après un mois de
juin particulièrement difficile le
propriétaire de ce château a retrouvé le
moral
beaucoup de touristes cet été ont choisi
le calme de la campagne et on en
profitait pour visiter quelques
monuments emblématiques on a une énorme
augmentation de la fréquentation
donc on a fait par rapport les dernières
sur juillet août + 25 % ce qui était
important pour nous beaucoup de gens de
la région
et puis aussi beaucoup d'allemands de
belges luxembourgeois et suisses en
bourgogne franche comté deux
départements tirent leur épingle du jeu
la saône-et-loire et le jura où les
touristes sont venus en nombre comme ici
à la cascade des tuffes d'après une
étude du comité régional du tourisme
toutes les activités en plein air ont
été largement privilégiée les chambres
d'hôtes ont fait le plein
les loueurs de vélos se sont bien
comportés les loueurs de bateaux aussi
c'est moins bon dans le tourisme urbain
là où il y avait des concentrations
moins de touristes à besançon ou encore
dijon est un gros coup dur pour bon
nombre d'établissements comme cet hôtel
restaurant au niveau de l'hôtel on a une
chute de 50% par rapport à l'an dernier
et quant à la restauration heureusement
on a un aux dijonnais fidèles et on est
arrivé à maintenir à 75 80 % du chiffre
de l'an dernier sur le mode duel mois
d'août mais aucune visibilité
on peut passer de cinq couverts un soir
à 45
ce manque de visibilité c'est bien tout
le problème des professionnels du
tourisme
personne ne sait dire à quoi ressemblera
la fin de l'année